dr nash in total transformation who is
sponsoring this next segment have been
transforming lives all across the valley
and for becky it is more than weight
loss take a look
i lost 42 pounds on dr nash's program i
am 7 pounds away from my goal if i can
do this i can do anything let's start
off with becky right there we saw her 42
pounds five dress sizes tell me more
about her success story this is unreal
yeah so becky is a school teacher who
had struggled for a very long time
trying to lose weight it just seemed
that every diet she tried would just
never seem to work either she couldn't
lose weight or her body couldn't hold it
and it's because she was just focusing
simply on eating less and moving more
but when we found the root cause which
was metabolic damage lurking under the
surface
she got the results that your viewers
were able to just watch in the clip why
why is it so hard to lose that stubborn
fat in your belly and your thighs why
are those two areas so hard right and
again this comes back to those metabolic
factors so unlike problems that are
simply caused by overeating or under
moving these stubborn areas are usually
also involving some kind of metabolic
problem
lurking under the surface and driving
the weight gain which is why for most
people simply eating less and moving
more does little if anything to change
those areas well what your program what
are the top three issues that your
program solves
right so when people are working with me
in my program typically what we're
dealing with is a dietary hormone
imbalance which literally works like a
light switch telling the body whether to
burn fat or store fat so we turn that
switch on we also usually have to go
after some form of inflammation and
inflammation makes the body use its own
belly fat kind of like an insulator to
protect itself from the inflammation
damage and then the final one is a
toxicity overload which clogs up and
stagnates the liver and the livers are
key organ that's going to turn our body
fat into fuel so switching these all
around is usually a game changer for my
clients and let's talk about results and
you
80 pounds you look beautiful this is
what over a decade ago how long ago did
you lose 80 pounds so i lost the 80
pounds back in 2009 but i'd actually
struggled with obesity for 25 years
before that in fact since i was 8 years
old so i understand it i was always
hopping from one program to the next
always chasing weight loss it wasn't
until i found out that i had damage and
went after the damage and forgot about
weight loss that my body finally changed
which means for me
i realized that it was the damage
driving the weight problem not finding
that special diet real quick before we
go your results becky's results these
typical results of your clients
these are typical results of my clients
when my clients do the strategies and
the protocols that i build for them
you're changing lives i love it yeah
especially you bring one every week what
do you got for us
of course so normally when people do the
online evaluation with me that
evaluation is 97
but because i go on las vegas now and i
get the opportunity to talk with jc
about these issues i always want to
bring something special so we have 10
online appointments available right now
on the website that's being shown on the
screen you get it for over 90 off less
than 10 to find out are you one of the
people dealing with this type of damage
and can we fix that problem once and for
all